were quite candid about this we've been
married three times you refer to Ted
Turner as your favorite ex-husband as
you just did
he's the favorite you have three x's and
he's the favorite I mean one of them's
dead but if he was alive
so if you're dead you're out of the
running okay all right but if he was
alive we would be friends I mean Life's
Too Short right I mean eventually you
remember why you love them and you
become friends again but Ted and I are
real close and yeah he's my favorite he
is such a character uh you know you when
you guys are married you lived in this
massive Ranch together
and for many massive ranches yeah he has
a million acres worth of massive Ranch
two million Acres right I used to buy
underwear in bulk
and then he didn't like to carry
suitcases so I would just so you had you
had to have a full set of clothes in
each different ranch right yeah that's
just boggles my mind and were you then a
ranchers would you have considered
yourself a Rancher I was a ranch's wife
you know I mean anyone who knows about
rancher you knows I'm I was a good I
would always sit on the outside when we
came to Gates usually you know a person
would sit in the middle so they wouldn't
have to get out but I was always The
Good Wife I would sit on the outside so
when we came to the gates I was the one
to get out and open the gates what wait
for the car to drive closing you know
when it's nice and it's dirty no if you
can afford to have 10 million Acres you
can afford a gate opener a clicker
they cost like 1.99
don't need that thing get out there
James
that's pretty much how he talks yeah it
is yeah absolutely get out there and get
that gate open yeah
um
didn't do that no
uh he's a huge he's really big into fly
fishing I know yeah I became a pretty
good fly Fisher woman
you changed politically correct yeah so
that means that uh because fly fishing
to me you just it looks like it's it's
said to be very hardest things to do
it's very hard and a lot of alpha male
in particular like to do it because you
have to be completely focused and
especially if they're deaf very focused
and nobody talks nobody you can have
things
a lot of guys including Ted oh okay and
me too apparently I didn't get that
uh no you you know you you have to just
focus if you think about anything else
you you miss it you know right one
second chance and and so you know guys
that have a lot of pressure and I guess
women to really like it and
it's about about a year doing a lot of
crying and throwing myself on the ground
but eventually I got pretty good yeah
that's worth it then to be a good fly
Fisher woman uh yeah did you have any
interactions with crazy animals if
you're living out there in 10 million I
keep adding acreage but you're on a 50
million acre ranch with apparently no
gate opener and uh were you uh did you
ever have interactions with crazy
animals I I did but my most crazy
actually was when after Ted and I split
up and I have a ranch in New Mexico and
one summer night I was sleeping my my
then very young grandson was in a crib
in the corner it was a very very small
cottage log cabin and a small room and I
was reading and I heard a weird noise
and it was about 10 o'clock at night and
I got up and went in the living room and
looked around and I couldn't
see anything and suddenly my golden
retriever came running out of the
bedroom you know yelping like crazy so I
went running in and there right in front
of me walking from the screen door that
he'd come through to that was a bear
headed for the crib where my grandson
was in the cab bedroom yes the bedroom
bedroom a very small Log Cabin bedroom
and you know I what do I do I don't know
where my gun is I don't have time to
look for it
so I so I do what you do I'm not going
to open this now because it's glued
together but I opened my bathrobe and I
went wow
you flash the bear
you flash the Bear right
but it wasn't the tits it was the growl
you don't know yes I do because he the
bear peed on the rug
so anyway and then the bear left I hope
The Bear Went part out of the way out
the door and sat down and I pushed do
that push you push the bear Force the
bear out and then slam the glass door
and the bear kind of leaned back against
the glass of his foot funny to look at a
bear mushed up against it's just like a
woman show him the goods and then kick
him out the door
[Applause]